[موسيقى]
لقب بالمضيف وبني له مذبح تقدم فيه
القرابين الى الهه العصر اليوناني انه
سوفكليس احد اعظم كتاب تراجيديا الاغريقيه
فضلا عن كونه بارعا في الجدل والمناظره
ومفكرا كبيرا
ولد في العام 496 قبل الميلاد لعائله ثريه
كانت تقطن في مدينه كولونوس باثينا حيث
كان ابوه يعمل في انتاج الاسلحه
يعد اغزر شعراء عصره في كتابه المسرحيات
تراجيديه ويقال انه كتب نحو 123 مسرحيه
نال الجائزه الاولى لمسابقات شعريه نحو 20
مره وحصل على المركز الثاني في جميع
المسابقات الاخرى لكن سبعا من تراجدياته
فقط بقيت الى يومنا هذا ابرزها اوديب ملكا
وانتنجون والكترا ويلاحظ ان بعض اسماء
مسرحيه سوفكليس اطلقها العالم النفسي شهير
سيجموند فرويد على امراض نفسيه مثل عقده
اوديب وعقده اليكسترا
بنيه كتاباته المسرحيه تشابهت الى حد ما
مع مسرحيات اسخيليوس ومع ذلك ابتكر سيفوكس
الكثير من الجوانب المسرحيه فادخل على
سبيل المثال شخصيه ممثل ثالث لمشهد واحد
على المسرح فحتى ذلك الحين لم يكن هناك
اكثر من ممثلين اثنين في المشهد الواحد
وقد جعلت هذه الفكره المسرحيه تتحرك بسرعه
اكثر ومنحتها عمقا اكبر
كان له حضور كبير في الحياه العامه وارتبط
بصداقات مع كبار الفلاسفه في ذلك العصر
مثل السقرات وافلاطون
تولى قياده الجيش في اثينا زمن بريكلس
وتولى ايضا منصب وزير خزانه وانتخب مرتين
لمنصب القائد العام ومستشارا في مجلس
اثناسي
توفي على الراجح سنه 405 قبل الميلاد عن
عمر نازل 91 عاما
من اشهر عباراته المنطق هو اكبر هدايا
الله للانسان
[موسيقى]